it's great to welcome to the program
today bill browder who is the ceo
of hermitage capital management head of
the global magnitsky justice campaign
and also author of the book red notice
um so bill to to start with the the
story you tell in your book
includes uh as you got into the world of
finance
your interest in eastern europe which
included
initially doing some work in poland when
there was relatively little work being
done in poland
by us and british-based folks in the
finance world
and eventually actually going to russia
itself
um talk a little bit about how that all
worked and how you ended up
working in that part of the world sure
so um
i went out to russia in 1992
just at the beginning of the russian
privatization program
basically when when the soviet union
broke up
uh russia became uh sort of you know
quote democracy
um uh the new president wanted to go
from communism to capitalism
and in order to do that they they
basically the state owned all the
property and they said we're going to
give all the property away for free to
the people
and make them capitalists and um
uh and and and of course as we know a
lot most of the property ended up in the
hands of a very small number of
russian oligarchs but there were little
crumbs falling off the table
and those crumbs were shares of some of
the biggest russian companies which were
trading on the stock market
and i went and set up a business called
the hermitage fund
to basically pick up those crumbs and
invest in the
newly privatized companies um and
for a while it was just uh bonanza like
bigger
profits you know i guess you know made
cryptocurrency
gains you know look like child's play
was just so
the the returns were so great so you
eventually got involved
in this space where there was the
possibility
of investing in russian companies
at massive discounts from
what traditional finance measures would
assess
as the value of these companies talk a
little bit
about how you how that worked how you
got into that
well so the situation was that that um
nobody really understood what was there
it was sort of a state secret
the oil industry was a state secret um
uh
you know all these big companies were
not known
um to the russians and the russians had
these these uh
vouchers they called them privatization
certificates and they could
invest their vouchers and whatever they
wanted to invest them in or sell their
vouchers
and most russians didn't really think
that their vouchers would be worth
anything and so they sold them for a
bottle of vodka and
and various people were were buying up
vouchers and this voucher exchange
exchanges formed and and i did the math
and
and i said okay if you buy shares and
some of these oil companies you're
buying
oil had like 10 cents per barrel of oil
reserves in the ground and at the time
oil prices were let's say trading at 30
and so 10 cents on the ground versus 30
out of the ground that that kind of had
to be a good deal
and so um but but to tell you the truth
it was
it was really hard to get people
interested in the west in that i would
say look here you know these things are
trading at a 99.9
discount and most people when they heard
the word russia they
like ran for the hills and so it wasn't
like um this was something
that was like the slam dunk you know
obvious
to most people most people said well you
know whatever the valuations are
i don't want to go anywhere near russia
so ultimately
um you fell out of favor in russia
um and ultimately were even
expelled from the country legal problems
what what went wrong how did the problem
start to develop
well so the companies that i so i ended
up getting becoming the largest
foreign investor in russia we had four
and a half billion dollars
invested in all these companies and what
i discovered was all the companies were
basically being robbed blind
by these oligarchs who were the majority
shareholders
and so um i decided to try to start
fighting the um the thievery the the
robbing of these companies by exposing
it and in doing so um uh
you know in in in these dictatorships
and third world countries
um business and politics are all sort of
intertwined and so
the moment that i started exposing all
these nasty things going on
um all of a sudden the politics got
involved and
and i was expelled from the country i
was declared a threat to national
security my offices were raided
they seized all of our documents and the
next thing we knew
those documents were used to perpetrate
a a
highly complex fraud where they then
stole our companies
and used those companies to steal 230
million dollars of taxes that my company
had paid
to the russian government and so it was
all
politics mixed with business mixed with
criminality
um and i was on the receiving end of all
that stuff
right so people may or may not know
but russia is a huge country
it has extremely rural areas
and those rural areas have courts
and often those courts are operating
under the direction of um uh who knows
who in power bribes corruption
etc talk a little bit about how that all
worked i mean that that was really the
basis for how
these assets and companies were taken
from you yeah so russia is a very
formalistic place so
so um it's not like you know in like i
don't know in
mexico or i don't know where you know
they just grabbed your stuff and that's
and then that's done in russia
everything is sort of done with some
kind of
pretense and and so they'll go to the
court
and the court just the judge will make a
decision to transfer your
assets to somebody else and he'll stamp
that he'll stamp the
uh judgment and and and so they they
love all this sort of procedural
bureaucratic stuff
um even though you can just you know
unwind it in
and show that it's all been done
fraudulently and for some reason that
that doesn't um
you know even if you can show us done
fraudulently that doesn't bother them
they can all just wave their court
decisions in the air
based on a you know 500 bribe they made
to the judge and
that's the order of magnitude of bribes
that they probably had to make in order
to get these kinds of decisions
through the chorus so you tell
one story and um
the way i like to sort of when i when i
read a non-fiction book about something
i'm not already familiar with i first
don't look up anything about it i just
read the book and then i'll look up well
what are the other
perspectives about it and after reading
your book and hearing your story
doing some research as well for this
interview i come across
allegations that you were not actually
the victim
but you actually were the perpetrator in
other words you use the systems
that you criticize and say that
victimized you to actually participate
in the corruption and in the fraud now
it's beyond my ability to adjudicate
these things in independently in the
context of this interview
you tell one story there are others who
tell another story
uh but what do you make of the fact that
there are these counter allegations that
have been made that say you are actually
the perpetrator here and not the victim
well i mean well first of all those
allegations were made
by the people who stole the money so um
and so so we have we have a uh uh i mean
and just so you know in in russia this
is what they do
they shoot down a plane going over
russia um
and they blame it on the on the the
people who were you know on the plane or
or i mean ev everything is the other
guys did it
and and uh in in our case uh
you know it's the whole thing is sort of
completely absurd from top to bottom the
money was stolen
um in so so our companies were stolen
and and all of these sort of
machinations were done
in to in in december like october
december of 2007
and we filed a criminal complaint with
with all the major russian law
enforcement
agencies after we learned about the
theft of our companies
and we put that onto the record
and three weeks after we filed our
complaint
the tax money was stolen the 230 million
dollars of taxes that we paid
and so what what criminals would would
file a complaint about their upcoming
crime
before they committed it i mean there
are so there are so many
like errors in their story they they
also blame the story
um that they say that that sergey
magnitsky my dead lawyer
um who was killed by the way for for
disclosing this
they say he stole the money and he did
it together with another dead guy
and the other dead guy died two two
months before the um the crime was
committed and so i mean
just you know these guys are like
keystone cops when it comes to
coming up with a conspiracy theory to
blame the other guy
so there um have been multiple red
notices
placed against you for people who don't
know what a red notice is a red notice
is
sort of a global interpol um
arrest warrant or arrest directive in a
sense
and there were ultimately interpol
decided as you tell in the book
not to enforce that red notice they
decided this is politically motivated
this is bogus and they decided not to
enforce it but there was a period of
time where
as far as you knew if you had an
interaction
with customs or border authorities
in any number of countries you could
have been arrested and then extradited
to russia and then
who knows what would have happened how
long was that period of time
where that was a concern for you where
you didn't know what would happen
well so the book um i finished writing
the book in 2014
and the first interpol um uh notice from
russia came in 2013.
the second one came in 2013 and since
the book was written
there have been eight interpol notices
for my arrest from russia and so when
you
say how long there's been numerous
periods of time
a week here two weeks there three weeks
um where
it where if i crossed a border i would
be arrested sent to russia
to my death and um i was arrested
in in may of 2018 i was traveling to
madrid
to meet with the spanish anti-corruption
prosecutor to share information
about russian uh money laundering
connected to the murder of my lawyer
sergey magnitsky
and as i was walking out of my hotel
room before my meeting with
with the spanish prosecutor two
spanish national policemen arrested me
on a russian interpol
warrant and it was only
because i was allowed to pack my bags in
my hotel room
before they took me away that i tweeted
out that i was being arrested
and then all hell broke loose with
journalists and
activists and everybody else calling
interpol
calling the spanish government calling
everybody else so that by the time i got
to the police station i was released but
um
uh this kind of stuff is pretty scary
and it continues to plague me up until
today the russians are after me
they've issued uh they've found me
guilty twice
in their courts in absentia and have
sent me since me 18 years in prison
um i'd be killed if i went back there no
question
yeah you you know what's interesting is
you you talk in the book
about how something that vladimir putin
will
do sometimes when he's asked about
individuals that are his adversaries and
this this happened with you he won't say
the person's name and so
there was a event you described in the
book where vladimir putin was asked
about you
and he referred to you i think as like
the gentleman you're referring to
when i was watching recently uh the
biden
putin press conference that took place
after their meeting
and putin was asked about navalny by a
journalist
it was almost verbatim what was said to
you putin
didn't say his name and said something
like
the person you're referring to
i believe has committed crimes in our
country which was i mean
that's essentially the same language you
describe is it not well
he used that language about me um on a
number of occasions
but but here's here's the interesting
thing so
after the magnitsky act was passed and
just for your listeners
um the magnitsky act is a piece of
legislation named after my lawyer sergey
magnitsky who was murdered
after uncovering this 230 million dollar
tax fraud
that these criminals and corrupt
officials committed
the magnitsky act was put in place in
the united states and other countries
which freezes the assets and bans the
visas
of russian human rights violators putin
got so angry
about the magnitsky act that he banned
the adoption of russian orphans by
american families
he made it his single largest foreign
policy priority
to repeal the magnitsky act he even sent
natalia veselnitskaya a russian lawyer
to trump tower
to meet with donald trump jr paul
manafort and jared kushner
before trump was elected to say if he's
elected please repeal the madminski act
um but here's here's the crux um
after the magnitsky act was passed he
started he he got
he had lost his he got so upset with me
that my name is now mentioned by
vladimir putin
and in fact he mentioned it very
profoundly um when he met with trump
when putin met with trump at the um
helsinki summit and at the end of the
summit
um uh there was this question about
whether the u.s whether russia would
hand over the
uh 12 gru officers who hacked the
election
and uh putin said yeah we'll hand them
over
if trump hands over bill browder bill i
so appreciate your time today
the book is red notice bill browder is
the ceo
of hermitage capital management and also
head of the global magnitsky justice
campaign
i really appreciate your time today my
pleasure great to see you